what number am I thinking of between 66
and 88-79 is that number and AGM chess
you got it and I have learned that I
need to go faster against this guy
giving me too many beatings there you go
Game one let's try I go with this again
let's try c4 and i think i'm going to
try and get that set up in that i did
like an accelerated form of a bad Vanek
system okay well I guess we're entering
a different territory now Black is
throwing that pond up there huh okay
let's just get some development in and I
think I might want to do something
different here I don't want to play III
I don't want to bring my night out and
get into this pond takes a for variation
I'm going to do something that's a
typical I don't know how good it is but
a little bit of experimentation I guess
now let's bring the night out I'm okay
with the Queen trade i'll look for play
along the a file from here so the main
reason behind this is that i wanted my
queen to just watch over sea for and
what I'd like to do is have my [ __ ] up
outside of the pawn chain and then
follow up with III okay now there is one
well hang on I don't have to worry about
this Bishop over here anymore do I if i
bring my bishop out this is something i
can recall doing over the board and a
blitz game bringing my bishop out and
then after pawn takes i can't recapture
with my queen as easily because be too
would hang so I think throwing a
question to the Queen first is best and
I'm really happy about the fact that
this Bishop is still struggling to do
something he usually is deployed first
f5 g4 if this Bishop was out here to one
of these two squares Bishop f4 would
available now it's now could actually
play to f4 if this Bishop was on one of
these two Bishop f4 if Queen takes you
get on b7 and then the rook and now just
completing my development I wonder if I
should hang on for a second what do I
mean by hang on
i think what i'm about to do might look
very weird I'm gonna do it though can
you figure out the reason for this why
did I go home with my queen why would I
have her dear to just go home like that
anybody know I don't know if I want to
share it maybe maybe you could do some
of the uh maybe you can figure out some
of the stuff why would I go all the way
home their main reason I wanted to make
sure I could keep this pawn on c5 I
wanted to have my rook defended so that
when be four comes in a 5 comes I could
play a 3 my rook is defended the Queen
drops back to the home square to defend
a 1 this is a purposeful idea when you
look at the good bad Bishop situation
he's considered the bad guy captured
towards the center unless I have a good
reason not to i don't believe i have a
good reason not to to take or not to
take I'm going to take I can't avoid the
light square Bishop exchange so I want
to make sure that this rook is
inconvenienced and next I think I want
to throw question to the Queen and I
want well I was going to play age 32
stop night here but my queen is there to
watch over and I think if my opponent
isn't able to pivot on this square it
becomes quite difficult if the Queen
goes to be seven I just hit the queen
with Brooke to be one there might be
some potential sacrifice on c5 let's
castle can I really do without castling
I don't think so whoa okay that's
supported now this night move so let's
drop back they don't want to deal with
that okay that's coming let's go here I
don't think that there's a better square
wanna get ripped b7 the king is going to
be quite vulnerable I think I do best to
just get on that right away rook is has
to be very nine
if Queen see a queen beats free there
might even be some tactical shots on
this square but what might be even more
active is Queen g4 and i think i'm going
to run forward with that my queen is
running a little bit short on squares
but okay I'm hitting the nighttime also
i have a checking square here this rook
my opponent is playing without a rook
time situation surprisingly enough i am
the one who is ahead if there is a
couple captures on this square my night
is there to recapture my cleanest hit
throw that check in there and actually i
could take on this square my queen is
not in any danger so now let me take
here I don't see any problem without Oh
actually I was thinking if the night
could eventually move here and attack my
queen she might be trapped but keep in
mind the bishop could maybe be taken
however rook here would be defending the
bishop and then night here would be
threatening to trap my queen hmm is that
a problem okay might be problem here
problem city do I have to do this move
and run away with my queen to h3 if the
night plays here I might have to do that
no no I wouldn't have to do that night
here I'd come to this square I'm not
afraid should I be it's double rooks to
17 night there I play back here in a pin
if the night goes back to d7 I can make
use of c7 so I'm up upon I have a all my
pieces where are at least my heavy
pieces are working keep this night into
pin night back here Queen here I'm
perfectly okay with Queen trades okay
we're going to have a queen trade okay
so position is simplifying and I think
my opponent is now going to
dropping this guy okay let me just
double check here night is ready to play
here fork these two pieces but double up
if the bishop moves i get the rook if
the bishop doesn't move i capture it can
the bishop be defended yes the night has
to go back but i'm fine with that if he
has to go home I just throw in a checker
no I hit that I attacked the pinch piece
again attack that pinch piece so now i
am going to be winning what exactly two
minor pieces for the rook at the very
least is there may be something better
all right I take here I really don't
want to go into that in balanced
position chop-chop-chop-chop ever gets
to active I don't want to go into that I
don't want to go into an unbalanced
position so let's stay active here
Bishop takes I take the rook first 124
to check now I want my night right here
I could maybe even just capture here
twice it's a little bit more tricky than
I would have liked actually get my night
working could have also thought about
bringing my other night at the one who
is further back the one that sound the
second-ranked instead of the third both
would be eyeing this square this truck
is still stuck he's passed but it's not
so easy to get him rolling my night
would come here with tempo it's a nice
thing let's get my other night working
King here deadly Forks pick my favorite
one mm-hmm it's got this one does it
really matter well I'm on the rook I
could do this to get my book back to the
seventh that might be light so is that a
lights-out move close to it I'm in at 32
32 night here think I gobble up another
pond get another pond uh-huh one of
those tricky nights though who was gonna
have the trickier night it's the big
question now who's gonna have to trick
your night run pond run because you're
fast and passed whoa why did I miss that
too passed pawns it's got to be good
that's got to be good
um what's my king doing puts like kick
doing okay let's get rolling King this
is a nice shield there's probably
something better I could have done yeah
ok I want to hang on to both pond still
I don't want even I don't want the King
to go there so I'm still cutting out the
king I'm okay with night trades I'll
just attack ponds go after these guys
and there's not much time in there in
time now run with the other guys quickly
and hopefully it can't be caught I don't
believe so okay resign okay good game
egm let's go back let's flip this board
and okay what's what to even say about
this I'm not sure about the decision to
block in the bishop with e 6 these are
some quick things that I think about
well then again you have to do something
about this don't you maybe it is ok but
if you are going to hem in your bishop
like this maybe it's important to strike
at this pond before my rook is defended
maybe that would be a better thing to do
instead of Bishop e7 or maybe at this
point because I'm i still can't support
this so maybe a timely b6 and then I
believe I'm having to capture and then
you recapture a different pawn structure
really a different game so consider b6
at this point I think
so early on there was a potential for
structural change again we got to see
why I did that exactly you grab some
space but I still have this bad guy bad
bishop outside the pawn chain so can't
be so bad typical attempt at trying to
break things down and I wonder if it
would have been better to have both a
and B file opened up now I think how you
did it is good because you do want to
get this move in and it would be much
more difficult to do that if this rook
was controlling a six so I think the
decision to take on c5 is maybe a good
one captured chase your queen around
your night ends up getting sidelined
there but it's to get the f5 advanced in
as well hmm i don't i don't know i think
it really it's coming back to that b6
move the timely b6 move before i drop my
queen back to d1 i think it's safe to
say that I'm the better side at this
point work out of play I have control
over the B file i make it inconvenient
for you to even contest it i have two
nights around still supporting the
center putting pressure on your center
and I think maybe there weren't even
points where I could have sacrificed not
so sure and maybe gotten this pond
running some concrete line would have
maybe been in my favor not so sure I'm
quite active at this point so yeah I
think it's dating all the way back to be
6 changing the structure instead of the
routine developing night here I think b6
is turning into a much different game in
maybe maybe you you're the one who
becomes the better side you have play
for your rook at the very least okay
just some quick points thank you ajm
chess